now one last thing we're going to do
just how see how we changed the scale
right what I'd like to do is go back to
your original data and let's copy that
one last time and let's use a some space
over here on the right to have one more
set here so we changed our scale we
multiplied everything by let's make it a
hundred times bigger because that's what
I wanted that's change of scale now what
I'd like is to do is change our origin
so this means we change where we measure
from okay so for instance what am I do
is I might say oh you know what I
measured all of your heights and you
were all wearing shoes okay every single
one of you was wearing shoes and I'm
just going to magically guess that
everyone's like size of their heels
would say two centimeters tall okay so
now I want your actual heights
I don't want those original ones what am
I going to do to take away that two
centimeter what am I going to calculate
original ones minus two right now my
original data is in meters so I'm not
going to do the original number take
away two I'm gonna do the original
number take away 0.02 yeah that would be
the effect of two centimeters oh yeah
you could that's fine I'm just for the
sake of consistently let's just start
from the original set of data and we'll
just muck about with that obviously you
could do it from centimeters subtract
two we could observe the same things I'm
gonna do the original data I'm gonna
take away that two centimeter heal so I
get your actual height I press Enter
okay now this is just one so what am I
gonna do with this to get the rest of
the data copy paste it all the way to
all my other rows and I get this okay no
this is what I want to ask right what
differences and what similarities are
there let's have a look at the variance
first I'm gonna highlight that in blue
can I ask you to compare a regional
variants and variance when I've changed
the origin what change was there
have a look real carefully maybe if I
just hide this middle one so I can make
it a bit bigger you can all see it a
little clearer huh have a look at the
numbers that numbers bang on right think
about that for a second what does
variance measure what is variance about
like the word itself tells you variance
is about how much variety is there how
much is this data spread out it's a
measure of spread yeah now when I took
all of you and I just subtracted the
height of your shoes right are you more
spread out
are you less spread out you're still
exactly as spread out as you were before
I've just taken two off everyone so
that's why the variance has not changed
tell me now without even looking at the
number tell me how much the standard
deviation is going to change its it
shouldn't change right
because standard deviation is the square
root of the variance we just established
that the variance did not change so
therefore your standard deviation also
should be the same does that make sense
okay and that's why all of your numbers
should match with one exception what
number has changed there's one
calculation that's changed I haven't
highlighted it yeah look carefully
which number which calculations actually
changed
said it again a bit louder Tyler yeah
yeah yeah standard deviation yep so just
look up the top there right I'm gonna
highlight this in what's another color
let's do green or something like that so
you can see it's different the expected
value which in this context is the mean
that's changed why is it changed we took
all our data and what do we do to all of
it we moved all of it down do you agree
so if you moved all your data down your
mean goes with you your expected value
also shifts down so therefore these
calculations down the bottom they are
dependent on the expected value so if
your expected value changed then those
guys will also change does that make
sense and hopefully you can see they're
all two centimeters shorter than what
they were before all right you've
shifted everything down